LOGAN URY: So it's my
pleasure to welcome
my friend, Moira, here today.
And we're so lucky
to have her with us.
She's a writer and
academic who is currently
part of the Harvard
Society of Fellows.
She just finished
her PhD at Yale,
so we should all
congratulate her afterwards.
And her work is fascinating.
It's at the intersection
of social theory,
along with histories of
labor, media, and technology
in the 20th and 21st centuries.
Her book, which we'll
be talking about today,
is called "Labor of Love,
The Invention of Dating."
And Moira is also
a founding editor
of "Logic," which is a new
magazine about technology.
Moira Weigel, thank
you for joining us.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Thank
you for having me.
LOGAN URY: Woo.
OK.
So just to kick it off, I
want to start by digging
into the book.
You've called the
book "Labor of Love,"
secretly an economic history.
What's the connection between
economic forces and dating,
and how has that played
out in the last century?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah,
well, there are
a lot of connections between
economic forces and dating.
I feel like, to backtrack
to when I was first
starting to think about
the book, part of why--
contrary to what it might
seem, I wasn't always obsessed
with dating, or at
least not anymore
than I think most
people probably are.
But one aspect of its history
that really interested
me is that this practice
that we call dating,
that we might take for granted
as sort of like natural
and not think about as
something historical,
is actually pretty
new in human history,
if you look at most societies.
It's not been the case that
young people go out and meet
one another on their own.
And it really only
emerges when you
start to have large numbers
of women in the workforce.
Dating is connected
to the economy
in a number of different ways.
But one of the big ways, and
part of why, as a feminist,
I was excited to
write about it, is
it only emerges
as a practice when
you have large numbers of
women going outside the home,
going outside private
space into public space,
earning their own money,
and taking control
of their own romantic
and sexual lives
in a way that really was
pretty unprecedented.
I mean, it's quite interesting,
because of course, this
happens differently-- my
book's mostly about America.
But we can watch this happen
in Asia in a different way,
or in Africa in a different way.
But the history of dating
is very tied to the history
of women entering paid work.
And then, of course, there
are some other ways, too.
I think that the ways we
think about love and romance
are totally shaped, in a
number of ways, by the way
we think about
economics, in terms
of being on the market, off
the market, hard to get.
These are all
economic metaphors.
So I think there's a kind of
economic unconscious to how
we think of a lot of
things about dating.
LOGAN URY: Absolutely.
So how has today's
economy reflected itself
in this age of Tinder?
MOIRA WEIGEL: What's the gig,
the sexual gig economy like?
I think that, like every
other aspect of our lives,
our romantic and sexual lives
are becoming more flexible.
And this has both positive
and negative aspects.
I feel like one reason
I wanted to write
the book was to push back
against all these kind of doom
and gloom narratives about
dating apps and online dating.
I feel like around 2012, 2013,
when I was first starting--
2013, 2014-- when I
was first starting
to think about these
questions, there
were a series of high
profile stories and books.
And I know that folks had
moms send these to them,
or saw them in another way.
But there was this
big end of men story
that was in "The Atlantic."
There was a huge "New
York Times" story
called "The End of Courtship."
There was all this anxiety
about hookup culture.
And I'm always interested
in these conversations
about crisis, because I think
it's where people actually
articulate what they believe men
should be and women should be.
So I'm always very
suspicious of them.
But at that time, anyway,
I was interested in all
these articles that
were basically,
like, humans have always met
and fallen in love in this way.
And ever since
caveman days, this
is how men and women
were until Tinder.
And now everything's over.
This, as a historian
and as a young person
who was still dating, this
seemed suspicious to me.
So part of why I wanted
to do this research
was, I was, like, well, it
can't really be the end of sex
and the end of men
and the end of love
and the end of courtship
all because of Tinder.
So what's behind that?
So anyway, that was
wanting to push back
against that narrative of
crisis around courtship
was part of how I got
into this project.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
That's something that really
fascinated me about the book.
It felt like there were these
moments of crisis every time
there was new technology.
And I actually found
it pretty comforting.
So you talked in
the book about how,
when the automobile came
out, people were like,
this is the end of morality.
And at these different
stages, people
had this moral hand-wringing.
So I would love if
you could talk us
through some of those moments.
And then also tell
us, is there even
such thing as traditional
courtship, this idea
that people seem to
think is being lost,
is that even
something that exists?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yes, totally.
So this will either
be really comforting
or really depressing, depending
how you think about it.
But one of the interesting
things about the history
of dating is that-- and to
talk about it, by the way,
people often--
I call it, in the subtitle,
"The Invention of Dating,"
and people are like,
well, what does that mean?
Haven't people always dated?
And I joke that dating
was invented in 1896.
It is the first
time that we see it
in the print record being used--
that word, in the way
that we use it now.
But basically, and again,
as I was saying earlier,
it's tied to women entering
the workplace and young people
in general moving to cities and
this new kind of urban culture
that you have emerging
in that period.
But when you go back
into the history,
the thing that is either
comforting or depressing,
depending how you
think about it,
is there has never been any
time or place in which people
are, like, dating,
great, killing it,
I'm sure I'm doing it right.
All the kids are doing it right.
We're not worried
about them at all.
It's constantly, from
the very beginning
of dating, dating is said
to be dying or in crisis.
And one of my favorite
research things
is that I learned that
during the first decade
or so that you have
women going out
with men on what we would
now think of as the most
traditional looking kind of
date, like going out to dinner
or going out to a movie, that
the person who would do this
are often arrested on
prostitution charges.
And a lot of the
early research I did
was in, like, vice squad
reports, because there
was no precedent for women
going out on their own
with men, or for money being
transacted in courtship.
When you think of a
Jane Austen novel,
Mr. Darcy isn't buying anything.
He's just going
to her living room
and hanging out with her mom--
Elizabeth Bennett,
that's her name.
So anyway, I think that back
in the very beginning, the very
first period where you have
this thing called dating,
you have not just hand-wringing,
but literally arrests
and people being dragged
off to reformatory.
And then throughout
the history, there's
this constant kind of
overtone of anxiety,
both from the grown ups
and from the people who
are participating in dating.
Because one thing
that's distinctive is
nobody ever knows--
unlike courtships
systems, where it's
controlled by parents or by
rabbis or priests or whomever--
a defining feature of dating is
that nobody knows exactly how
you're supposed to do it.
And that's always been true.
LOGAN URY: Right.
So let's paint a
picture for people
who haven't read the book.
What came before dating?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
So in the book, of
course, everywhere
has their own variables
and their own situations.
But the dominant
middle class system
of courtship in the 19th
century is called calling.
And again, it's the Jane
Austen scenario, right?
You sit in your living room.
Your mom, your aunt,
your sisters are there.
Gentlemen callers
can come visit you.
It's almost-- and
since I'm an academic,
I always think of it as a kind
of awkward, like, office hours,
romantic kind of situation.
LOGAN URY: No one
ever goes to those.
[LAUGHTER]
MOIRA WEIGEL: They do.
No one wants to come
to my office hours.
But yeah, so calling it
as a system of courtship
is symbolically important.
I mean, I believe that all
of our social practices
encode all kinds of
beliefs about how
we think the world works
and what kinds of rules
different people should perform.
But it locates courtship
in the home, right?
So it's in the
territory of the family.
It's being supervised.
It is supposed to
be non-economic.
No money is exchanged.
I mean, the thing
that's very interesting
is that it's also
very much understood
to be in control of the women.
I read-- there's an advice
column in "The Ladies Home
Journal," which is the
most popular magazine
in the world around 1900.
And there's an advice
columnist called the Lady
from Philadelphia, who answers
people's romantic questions.
And she would get these letters
from young men saying, oh,
can I go call on a young woman
if she hasn't invited me?
And the Lady from Philadelphia,
contrary to our belief
that men are always
the initiators,
says absolutely not.
You know, you can't.
If a woman doesn't
want to see you,
you can't go show up at
her house in this way.
So there's this
important sense in which
the calling system makes women
like the hosts of courtship.
And this dramatically
changes when
courtship moves from the
living room, with mom and dad,
into the public sphere,
which historically
has been seen as the sphere
of men, the sphere of money,
the sphere of the market.
LOGAN URY: So it's the
predecessor to Bumble.
Women have to make
the first move?
MOIRA WEIGEL:
Something like that.
Think about it-- if
your mom were on Bumble,
watching [INAUDIBLE], maybe.
LOGAN URY: Great.
So we'll talk about
that in a little bit,
in terms of these
ideas that we think
are deep seated into our DNA,
and actually are relatively new
inventions.
So one thing I read was that
you had initially thought
of things like dating
and relationships
as maybe too silly or trivial
to warrant serious study.
How did you change and
come to write this book?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah,
well, this book,
as my PhD supervisor would
be happy to tell you,
was a distraction from
my main PhD research.
It wasn't what I was supposed
to be working on at Yale, where
I was in grad school.
I feel like, again,
about this time when
there were all these
stories coming out--
which I see, in a
way, as a reaction
to the financial crisis.
I mean, we could have a longer
conversation about this,
but why around 2013, 2014, there
was all this anxiety in the air
about men aren't
acting like men,
and women aren't-- you know,
kids aren't dating properly.
But in that moment,
I was in grad school.
I was getting trained in
all these ways of looking
at theory and history.
But of course, on my own
time, I spent all my time
with my friends talking about
love and sex and romancing,
not all of it, but
quite a lot of it.
And I feel as if I came to
this point where I realized,
we're all developing these huge
intellectual tool kits to look
at certain kinds of questions.
But why don't we take this other
kind of question seriously?
And I think, in a very
deep way, you know,
dating, for better or worse, is
the system that our culture has
in place for reproducing the
world, forming social bonds,
for entering biological
reproduction,
for setting up kinship networks.
There's very little that's more
serious than that, actually.
And I think that there's
actually something
really kind of sexist and
conservative about treating
some of these topics
as if they don't
warrant serious
intellectual consideration.
I mean, I think it's
kind of funny to have
this whole cultural
system, especially
if you're a straight woman,
where you've grown up
your whole life with
magazines and movies and books
and all of these cultural
signals telling you here's
what you should want,
here's how you should
be if you want to be
loved, which, by the way,
is the most important
thing about you.
And then the minute
that you're, like,
I have a question about that.
It's like, it's not serious.
Don't waste serious intellectual
energy looking at this.
So I feel as if I
came to the project
kind of extracurricularly
in graduate school.
But then once I started thinking
about it and all the ways
that our romantic
beliefs are enmeshed
in deep social beliefs,
historical practices, that kind
of thing, I really felt,
it felt important to take
a serious intellectual
lens to look
at the sources of these
messages and the work
that they were doing in terms
of teaching us to desire.
LOGAN URY: Well, I'm so
glad you did write the book.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, thank you.
LOGAN URY: And I
was wondering if you
would read this passage for us.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, dear.
Sure.
LOGAN URY: And then I have
a follow up question on it.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Ooh.
Look at this.
All right.
I began to feel a need
to write this book when
I sensed that I was trying to
make a life according to rules
I did not understand and that
the process had blinded me
to my desires.
Following my desires was
supposed to be the point.
Yet I had never
reflected long enough
to discover whether the
feelings that I believe
should be there actually were.
I had no idea who I was.
And as long as I
kept impersonating
all the women I
thought I should be,
I could not receive
love, much less give it.
I had no self to
choose to give it from.
True story.
So if you ever feel
moved to laugh,
or it seems like I'm
trying to be funny,
just, like, feel free.
LOGAN URY: So based
on that passage
and based on what you know
now, I'd love to ask you
what advice would you
give 16-year-old Moira?
And more broadly, if
you could design a class
that every high school
girl had to take
before entering
adult relationships,
what would you include
in that course?
MOIRA WEIGEL: OK, these
are big questions.
I think-- and I'd be very
curious to hear from people
here--
I think what's
interesting, if you're
a certain kind of ambitious,
Type A, high achieving,
straight woman especially,
you receive this one set
of messages about your career.
And you're supposed
to be confident
and you're supposed to be
able to act in all these ways.
And then you receive,
basically, opposite messages
about your love life.
And indeed, not only are you
not supposed to show initiative,
you're supposed to do all this
extra work to cover up the fact
that you have those traits.
So I feel as if--
I mean, 16-year-old Moira, who
knows what could have helped.
But if I could have known
anything earlier, I think--
I don't know, I would
have liked to be
more aware of the ways
in which these rules that
are given to us and these things
that we're taught about how
to be if we want to be desirable
serve all these incentives that
are not necessarily our own.
It's an excellent way
to sell women things.
Like, anxiety-- it's, like, tell
a woman that something that she
didn't even know was a
thing is wrong with her,
and then sell her
the thing to fix it.
It's like an engine of quite a
lot of the economy in general.
But I feel as if, yeah,
this way in which you
get so many messages that are
also always about repressing
your own feelings.
If you think, and we can talk
about this, but if you think
about how many self-help
franchises are basically,
like, whatever you
might feel like doing,
do the opposite thing.
Don't do that.
Don't show your feelings.
Don't express your desires.
I think being aware of the
ways in which that grows out
of history that's
deeply sexist and serves
institutions and
practices that are deeply
sexist would have been
helpful and probably would
have made me less anxious and
self-hated in various moments.
What was the other
thing, a syllabus?
LOGAN URY: Yeah, I mean,
it's kind of a combination.
It's like, what would
16-year-old Moira
have benefited from knowing
with what you know now?
But what would women in
general benefit from knowing?
And I think the
answer of just be
skeptical of somebody
telling you that something's
wrong with you and
then trying to sell you
something to fix it is
good advice for all of us.
MOIRA WEIGEL: And I think also--
and it's hard for us to do,
and it's especially hard
to do in romance, because
we all have so much at stake
personally and want
to make things work--
but also to think structurally
and systemically sometimes
can be very helpful.
But I think that this is the
opposite of what we usually
want from self-help.
Usually, what we want is a
totally normal fair thing
to want--
is we're, like, what
are the 10 tricks that
will help me navigate
this situation, you know,
whether it's
professional or personal.
But I think that what is
exciting and radicalizing and
liberating about
studying history
is you see how many of
these issues and problems
are, in fact,
structural and social.
And there's quite
a lot of work left
to do before women are
romantic equals, or equals
of any kind, in all kinds
of social situations,
substantively and meaningfully.
And those solutions can't all
be done by working on yourself
personally.
LOGAN URY: Is that
a real pep talk
that you've given your
friends, where they're, like,
what's wrong with me?
And then you're,
like, it's not you.
It's market forces and
society and 100 years
of sexist institutions
that have contributed
to where you are today.
MOIRA WEIGEL: More than 100.
I think that I have--
trying to think of specific
friend and specific pep talks.
I mean, I think this sense in
which the answer that we get
is so often work a little
harder on yourself, do
a little bit more about this.
I think that the idea
that it's that's not,
the problem isn't always
you, is certainly a thing
that I've stressed to friends.
Whether I talk about market
forces when comforting
a friend, I hope I don't.
LOGAN URY: So I want to
talk a little bit more
about what you mentioned
about self-help books.
So you make this really
great point in your book
that if you go to a
bookstore and you walk down
the self-help aisle, on your
left-hand side you might see
all the career books
that tell you lean in,
work harder, don't
speak with uptalk.
And it's all about
really putting effort
in toward your career.
And then on the
right-hand side could
be all of these books
about your love life
that say, whatever you want
to do, do the opposite.
And--
MOIRA WEIGEL: It's
not him, it's you.
LOGAN URY: Yeah, I think I'll
quote you here, when you said,
if you want to call him, don't.
If you want to sleep
with him, don't.
If you slept with him and you
want to call him afterwards,
don't.
And it's true.
MOIRA WEIGEL: It's like the
rules is literally 32 chapters,
each one of which is, like,
don't do this thing that you
want to do.
LOGAN URY: Right.
So I think it's fascinating to
just explore how on one hand,
we're being told to
put so much effort in,
and on the other hand,
we're told to be passive.
So how do you
navigate that tension?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Wow.
It's a big question.
I mean, I think that,
again, to look to history,
a thing that interests me is
to go back to the beginning
when we were saying how this
whole phenomenon of dating
is predicated on women
being in the workforce,
being mobile in cities,
having certain kinds of agency
that we haven't had
historically, that it's then
that you start to see all
this romantic advice as
almost like a
reaction or an attempt
to control female sexuality,
given that it's no longer being
controlled by mom and dad
and the rabbi or the priest.
I think that-- sorry--
I think that that perspective
was very interesting to get
while researching the book.
It was fun to look at 19th
century advice, advice
for calling, because people
were also anxious about calling.
But there wasn't this
emphasis on deceit.
I feel like in
contemporary self-help,
there's so much emphasis--
and I mean this, by the way,
for straight people.
Fascinatingly, self-help for
queer people is very different,
and I think shows
how much of this
is about reinforcing certain
binary gender roles, actually.
But there's so much
emphasis on not
showing too much
about how you feel
or covering up your desire.
And this really only
emerges with dating.
In this earlier era,
there's much more
emphasis on sort of
sincere self-expression
and straightforwardness.
And I think that in a lot of
ways, from a macro perspective,
this is about controlling
female sexuality
and how anxious it makes a
culture broadly for women
to have certain kinds of
liberties that they hadn't had.
LOGAN URY: And also, if you
tell women men are from Mars
and women are from
Venus, it's a lot easier
to sell both of them a book
to explain the other gender.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah,
exactly, I feel,
like, very, very many self-help
books can kind of be summarized
as, what dudes are like, by
a dude, what women are really
like, by a woman.
That this sort of
mutual mystification
of men and women to each
other is a very good engine
for selling both sides things.
LOGAN URY: So this
whole idea about women
need to be passive in
dating, it's often chalked up
to this evolutionary legacy.
Can you talk a
little bit about that
and where some of that
pseudo science emerges from,
and how that impacts us today?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
Well, I think, I don't
know, have folks seen,
I feel like maybe this
trend has peaked and gone
down a little bit.
But I feel like the
[? ev ?] site click bait,
the article that's
like, did men evolve
to like women in high heels?
Like, yes, click it.
This is sort of like a
kind of a piece that--
LOGAN URY: Well,
there's that new book
that came out "Casual
Sex", about how
Tinder is affecting monogamy.
And I think it reinforces
a lot of these ideas.
So it's still--
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, what
does that book say?
LOGAN URY: I
haven't read it yet.
I just read an article about it.
But it was basically saying that
men had to become monogamous
in order to get married, which
gave them access to women
and an ability to reproduce.
But now with Tinder, men
have this easy access to sex
when they want.
So there's this bifurcation
between the place
I go for sex and the place I go
for marriage, which is leading
fewer people to want marriage.
MOIRA WEIGEL: It's
really amazing
how many respectable academics
and scholars in 2017,
it's never occurred to them
that women might also enjoy sex.
But it's like there's still
this idea that heterosexuality
is this depressing truce
whereby women give as little sex
as they can get away
with for affection,
and that men do the opposite
or the contrapositive,
whatever the mirror
image of that is.
I think that it's
very comforting
to believe that
certain phenomena are
natural or biological
or are hardwired in,
like the Pleistocene era.
And we all love--
we don't, I don't, I love
carbohydrates-- but many people
love Paleo diets, or this idea
that something was natural
and it's how cave people did
it, so it's how we should do it.
I think that this is very
rarely a useful framework
for explaining human behavior.
We're social creatures.
We're historical creatures.
This isn't just some
wishy-washy kind
of social construction thing.
Brain scientists talk about
the plasticity of the brain
and how quickly it can change.
Scholars of gene expression
talk about how much
environmental factors
trigger and shape which genes
express themselves or not.
So this idea that the
nature of heterosexuality
was established by cave people
and we're still somehow acting
that out, always to me
seemed very circular
in all sorts of ways.
You know, it's often--
Stephen Jay Gould, who is
the evolutionary biologist
at Harvard, described this kind
of story as "just so" stories,
but also, just not that
useful a mode of explanation.
As I was suggesting earlier,
you look back at advice columns
from 1905, and they say
totally different things
to what we say now
about who should
take the initiative in
a courtship situation
or whose role it is.
So I think that humans are
much stranger and more flexible
than this kind of
narrative suggests.
And it's really
comforting sometimes.
I think, it's kind of--
ev psych narratives are
comforting to everybody.
If you are a conservative
in certain gender beliefs,
it's reassuring to
think, like, oh, things
won't change that much.
This is how people are.
And if you're frustrated
by the lack of progress,
it's like, your
boyfriend is not a jerk.
He evolved not to pick up
the dry cleaning, you know?
So I think that
these narratives are
very appealing as click bait.
But I think that
they don't really,
they're not very
useful, actually,
in terms of their
explanatory power.
And there have
been many critiques
within academia of evolutionary
psychology specifically.
It's funny.
This is one of these modes
of thought that's existed
and it's popularized
for much beyond,
much longer than it's existed in
its institutionalized academic
form.
LOGAN URY: I love how
you called it click bait.
And I think it's interesting
to note that it's neither
helpful for explaining
gender roles in dating nor
for why there are fewer
female engineers at places
like Google.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, dear.
Is there a question?
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: Implicit question.
MOIRA WEIGEL: An
implicit question?
Yeah, I think that--
I mean, this is a very charged
thing to talk about here.
Again, I would just say
I think that explanations
that refer to some kind of
absolute natural disposition
are not usually very useful.
And usually, when you go
back to the scientists who
are being cited do not
hold up to scrutiny.
I think that there are
gender distributions,
it's not that there's no
differences among genders.
But I think that,
usually, it'll be
like the brain scientists,
when you ask them,
say 10% of this difference is
due to gender, and 90% of it
is due to other factors.
There are more differences
among people than--
in this one class than
across the classes.
And so I think that, again, it's
reassuring to certain people
to believe that what
is natural is good
and that nature sanctions a
certain kind of social order.
But I think this is
usually not a very useful
and certainly not a
very progressive way
to think about our
relations as humans.
LOGAN URY: So I just want to
underline your point, which
is that if anyone does
point to these things,
like women being
passive and men being
the aggressor in
relationships as natural,
even looking back 100 years,
things were totally different.
So it isn't really
based in history.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah,
no, and indeed,
history provides plenty
of counter examples.
I mean, that's
what's so cool to me
and exciting about
studying history,
is it's so much
weirder than you think.
And our social arrangements
are so much more contingent
than you might
imagine, which also
means that they can be changed.
Incidentally, I'm sure
everyone here knows this,
but programming is originally
a female profession,
predominantly.
There's a great new book
about this by my friend,
so I'm going to tout it.
It's called "Programmed
Inequality,"
about the pushing out--
I've been doing a little
research at MIT on this--
but the pushing out of female
programmers in the 1980s,
basically from their profession.
So the idea that the current
gender distribution reflects
some sort of timeless
biological reality
rather than a certain set of
social arrangements, to me,
seems pretty tenuous, when
you look at as recently
as the 1970s and 1980s,
the gender distributions
were that different.
LOGAN URY: I'm excited to
talk to you about that later.
Yeah, I have a lot of
thoughts on that one.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Take
the microphone off
and talk about it later.
LOGAN URY: So in
this conversation,
you've identified
yourself as a feminist.
But I read, or I heard
in another interview
you did, that you didn't
always identify as a feminist.
And in fact, you felt like you
could overachieve your way out
of these glass
ceiling situations.
What's been your
journey from feeling
like that was a possibility
to where you are now?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
I think-- I love this question.
And I'd be very
curious, I don't want
to put anyone on the spot, who
identifies as a feminist here?
Yeah.
And I think that--
LOGAN URY: Most of the room.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Most of the room.
Did anyone else, maybe
this is a question people
have to think through, but
experience this thing of not
identifying that way,
and then in their 20s
or in a later life period,
coming to identify that way?
Yeah, because I think
the only thing that
makes me feel less
embarrassed of how long
it took me to identify that
way is how many brilliant women
I know who say
something similar.
I think that part of it, I'm
sure, I grew up in the '90s.
I'm sure part of it was the
historical mood when I grew up.
But I also think until
you reach a certain age,
there's this way
that you imagine,
as a young woman
of a certain kind,
that if you're just good enough,
if you're just good enough,
it won't apply to you.
It's amazing.
I'm thinking about this because
of the Harvey Weinstein stuff
today.
It's amazing when I think about
how many women I admire have--
since we've gotten a bit older--
talked about getting sexually
harassed at work and how
it's systemic and prevalent,
that is.
But I think that
when you're younger,
you just think, you know,
if I just do this right,
or if I'm just smart enough,
or I'm just good enough,
surely this won't apply to me.
And nobody wants to
identify with a class that's
systemically disadvantaged.
You know, nobody-- and this
comes back to your question
about what's
trivialized and what's
treated as unserious, and
sort of pink and frilly,
is female things.
So I think that, gosh, it's hard
for me to pinpoint the moment.
And I do think something
in the zeitgeist changed.
Like, if we look at
that moment, I always
think of Beyonce at the VMAs in
front of the big feminist sign.
But there were many things in
the air in 2013, 2014, I think.
You know, "Lean In,"
Sheryl Sandberg's book,
all sorts of other
cultural signals
suggested that feminism was
trendy for the first time
in our lives.
I'm sure that influenced me.
But I think that a lot of it
is just growing up and entering
more professional situations
or more adult situations,
when you realize that you
can't overachieve your way out
of anything or
everything, that it's
like these structural things do
indeed apply to you, no matter
how excellent you may be.
And of course, this
applies, it goes
without saying, across
[? intersectional ?]
identities.
It's not just women.
This is true for all
kinds of groups that
are historically oppressed.
But I think that,
yeah, I think it
was the experiences in my 20s.
And also dating really
terrible men, if I'm honest.
But both in work
and in love, I think
that I came to that realization
or to that identification
belatedly.
LOGAN URY: Yeah, I mean, this
really resonates with me.
I mean, we're similar ages.
And everything you
said about, like,
if you grow up on
the Powerpuff Girls
and Spice Girls and
Girl Power and being
told that girls can do anything,
you sort of believe it.
And you don't want to
identify with people
who are having a
harder time and maybe
who haven't experienced it.
But at a certain point,
being the teacher's pet
or doing everything right
doesn't necessarily serve you
and there's
structural things that
are actually
affecting you at work
or affecting you in academia.
And I even feel like
in Silicon Valley,
a lot of risk taking
behavior is really valued,
which in some ways is at odds
with this teacher's pet persona
that a lot of women
are forced into.
So it's something
I've been observing,
which is for women to be
successful and take risks,
they almost have to shed
that teacher's pet persona
that they were praised
for for the first 18 or 22
years of their lives.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah,
it make sense.
And of course, this runs
into issues with age, too.
But it's easier to
take risks if you
have no caring
responsibilities or children
or other kinds of things
that are disproportionately
put on women.
So of course, this value
that's placed on risk taking
has certain gendered
elements, as well.
But it's true, I think I was
raised to be a very good girl.
I was a very good
girl for a long time.
And you do everything
you're supposed to,
and realize that it,
nonetheless, doesn't get you
out of the situation
you might be in,
or that that experience
can be very radicalizing.
But I think I realized-- this
became a plot line on the show
"Insecure" recently,
which I love.
LOGAN URY: Oh, I'm a big fan.
MOIRA WEIGEL: I love it, too.
LOGAN URY: Wait, what part?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Shoulds,
how much I realized
I thought in should statements.
It's like, oh, I should.
I talk about [INAUDIBLE].
LOGAN URY: Oh, are you a Molly?
MOIRA WEIGEL: I guess so.
LOGAN URY: Yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
MOIRA WEIGEL: I don't know if
I'd claim to be a fully Molly.
I don't know if I
get to claim that.
But I definitely-- and I open
the book talking about this--
but I realized that I thought so
much about what I should want,
or what I should want to do,
or what I should be doing.
Was I doing the right things?
And that it's really hard
to shake that and be like,
what kind of-- you can't
"should" about a want.
What do you want?
But that we're very
socialized to think
about what's the good thing to
do or the right thing to do.
LOGAN URY: Right.
I mean that feels like a
very familiar narrative.
If I do these things, I
will be desirable versus
what do I desire?
And how oftentimes when I
de-brief with people after they
go on dates, they talk
all about whether or not
the person seemed
interested, but they
don't get to the
point where, did they
like that person or not.
And I try to get
them to that point.
But it's interesting that
our brains don't naturally
say, what do I want?
It's what should I want or
how can I get them to want me?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
LOGAN URY: So it's something
we're working through.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Absolutely.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
So we've talked a
lot about how dating
is this arena where people
play out these gender roles.
And we have these
scripts we've inherited,
whether it's through books
or culture or movies.
If people in this room
or people watching online
want to flip those scripts, what
are some things that we can do?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Wow.
I really do think
a recurring theme
that I came across in
the different areas is
that despite this tendency
of the self-help industry
to mystify men and women
to each other, actually
most humans want
more similar things.
You know, most humans want some
combination of sex and intimacy
and respect and communication.
And I think that one of
the most harmful scripts
is this idea that men and
women are essentially at odds
and that all gender
and sexual relations
are this sad compromise
of women, for whom sex
is like work, and for men, it's
like recreation or something.
But that's a whole other topic.
So I think that it's
really important
to get out of that script.
And I think, yeah,
I don't know, I
think there's so much
gamification there.
This idea that it's a
game where you master--
I mean, "The Rules"
and "The Game,"
these are the two most
successful dating franchises
of the past decade or so.
But I think that trying
to get beyond these games
and this idea that partners
are mysterious to one another
and do this slightly more
challenging emotional work
of being in touch
with one's own desires
is the most fundamentally
important thing.
And scripts-- I mean,
in some of the research
that I cover on hookup
culture, it's so funny.
You get these young
men again and again,
saying, well, I imagine everyone
else is having so much sex.
And I feel sad, but I
shouldn't, because I'm a man.
And this is what men
are supposed to want.
And it's, like, first of
all, none of your classmates
are having as much
sex as you think
they are, or very few of them.
And second of all, you
can't should about a want.
You know, if you
feel sad about this,
and you feel you
shouldn't because you're
supposed to be masculine
and it's not masculine,
that belief, again, about
this absolute gender
difference and different aims is
producing a lot of unhappiness.
It's actually very
counterproductive for everyone
involved.
LOGAN URY: Do you feel
optimistic about the generation
younger than us?
MOIRA WEIGEL:
Yeah, I think I do.
I think I do.
I think the kids are all right.
I think that we
always have to think
about class difference
and geographic differences
and it's very hard
to generalize.
But I think the
generation below us
has better gender and
sexual politics than I
did at their age, anyway.
I think that there's a way in
which the internet is creating
new kinds of discourse
and awareness.
I think that there is,
despite the depressing state
of affairs, this apocalyptic,
smoky state of affairs
in America, generally,
there's a lot
to feel hopeful about
with young people.
LOGAN URY: Well, since you
are on a college campus,
and in fact, the college campus
that you and I attended--
MOIRA WEIGEL: It's true.
LOGAN URY: --I would be curious
to see whether women who are
undergrads right
now, whether they've
been affected by sort of what
you called the Beyonce 2013
feminism.
So basically,
either on one hand,
they are more feminist than we
were when we were in college,
or it's just an age
thing and maybe they
will reach that
point of identifying
as a feminist later.
MOIRA WEIGEL: I think--
I suspect some
people in this room
might be younger than I
am, so we could ask them.
But I think that feminism
is trendier than it
was when we were in college,
that this idea, I can't think
if I have any hard
numbers to prove this,
but when I think of when I
encounter young women now
who are in college
or around that age,
they think it's cool
to be a feminist.
And that's a thing
they identify as.
I think that Beyonce and Hillary
and Sheryl and all these women
helped produce that moment,
which I think is basically--
Chimamanda Nazi Adichie--
that we should all
be feminists moment that that
really resonated, which I think
is basically a great thing.
I think that there
are limitations to--
I don't know, sort of the
transformation of feminism
into a lifestyle
brand, or that it's
this thing that you can just
make a choice individually
to be this way and
that that will fix all
the problems that women face.
I think that there
are limitations to it.
But basically, the kids
are more politically aware,
more politically engaged, maybe,
than we were at their age,
certainly around these
questions of gender.
LOGAN URY: That's great.
Yeah, I do find that
really comforting.
And this idea that there
is more gender fluidity
and flipping the
scripts and that people
at least, whether or not
feminism is being commodified
in some ways, it's at least
giving people the space
to say like, hey, maybe we
shouldn't wear really short
skirts so we can get
into that final club
and see if we're on the list.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
I think that that
does feel, again,
there's a lot more
work to do, but that
feels like a basic improvement.
I think it wasn't even a
conversation my friends
and I were having when
we were undergrads,
at least not with
the same explicitness
and emphaticness
that we see now.
LOGAN URY: Or it was the
idea from from 9:00 to 5:00,
you were in class, and you were
killing it and answering all
the questions and doing well.
But then, what happened at
night was a different part
of your personality.
And my hope would be that
people are more unified
in being that strong
woman during the day
and in the evening.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
I think what's
perverse, again, we
were both undergrads at Harvard.
And I imagine a
lot of people here
are also a certain kind of type
that we saw a lot in college.
I think what's hard is that we
were very conditioned to want
to succeed and get approval.
And you get that for one set
of things, professionally
or academically, and you get it
for a different set of things,
socially and sexually.
And so there's no
real contradiction
between being the
straight A student who
wears a teeny, tiny skirt and
stands outside the finals club
at night.
They're both ways
of seeking approval
from institutions of authority.
And the men own the real estate
for the finals clubs, too.
I mean, there's this deeply
gendered system of social power
that we were really
responding to.
It wasn't just in our heads.
So it's this weird way that
it's like you're overachieving
by being what someone else
wants, whether it's on your CV
and about a boss or a teacher,
or about looking cute at night.
And I think that it takes
a lot of personal strength,
and also political solidarity
in these more collective forms
of thinking, to change that.
And I do think it's happening.
LOGAN URY: I love
that perspective.
Yeah, I think it's hard
for an 18-year-old,
or certainly would have
been hard for me, to say,
oh, success during the day
is doing well in my classes
and success at night is
standing up to the patriarchy.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah?
Well, hopefully, we
can make standing up
to the patriarchy cool.
I think it's already cool.
LOGAN URY: On its way, yeah.
So I do want to leave time for
questions from the audience.
Before we get to that, I'm going
to ask you one more question.
So this is something
I ask all my guests
who join me for these
talks at Google.
There is the Google.com home
page that has the Google logo.
And then underneath
it sometimes,
there's this line of text.
So if you could write the
line of text for one day
and millions of
people would see it
as they do their
billions of searches,
what would you put
on that line of text?
And since this is a modern
romance talk, maybe what would
that line be to help people with
their dating and relationships?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, my gosh.
LOGAN URY: Yeah, no
pressure, though.
MOIRA WEIGEL: No pressure.
I think, because I
usually think of Google
with those wonderful drawings.
LOGAN URY: Oh, yeah,
we do have drawings.
MOIRA WEIGEL: --when I look.
I'm a terrible drawer, actually.
LOGAN URY: You could commission
a Google Doodle for something
that's on your mind.
MOIRA WEIGEL: No, I've
been thinking a lot--
and again, I feel like
we've just scratched
the surface of this history.
But I've been thinking a lot
about the leftist and feminist
slogan, "None of us are free
until all of us are free."
And that might seem like
a stretch from dating.
But I think that there's
a way in which we
can have fun at romance,
and we're not always
supposed to be thinking
about the structural
and the political.
But men and women,
and again, we've
hardly talked
about queer dating,
which is the funnest part of
dating history, by the way.
But I think that we can't--
it's all very well to say
that we're more flexible
and that we're more permissive
about romantic relationships
and family structures
and all these things.
But men and women
can't really meet
as full romantic
equals until we address
these kinds of underlying
social and structural problems.
So again, there's
sort of these two--
there's always this double
vision between the personal
and the social.
But I think that the
idea that none of us
are sexy until all of
us are sexy, "none of us
are free until all
of us are free"
is a sentiment I've been
thinking about a lot.
So that's my grand
claim to stake
on the bottom of
the Google homepage.
LOGAN URY: I love that.
Well, maybe somebody
out here today
can actually get that on there.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, yeah.
LOGAN URY: OK.
So now we'll open it up to
questions from the audience.
And Scott has a handheld mic.
AUDIENCE: I'm really interested
to hear your perspective
on race within dating,
race or ethnicity.
I recently heard
a podcast on NPR
about dating apps and how
it's completely skewed when
it comes to race.
And throughout history or just
what your perspective on it
is now in current times.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
I mean, this is a great
question, and a huge question.
I think that there
is all this data.
And one thing that's interesting
about the proliferation
of these apps is it
does give us much more
measurable information
about people's preferences
and behaviors.
There's certainly a lot of
disappointing information
that's come out of
OkCupid and other apps
in terms of how forms of social
prejudice that we see elsewhere
in society play out in dating.
There are so many things to say.
I mean, historically, one
thing that's really interesting
is that dating as
a practice really
emerges out of the working
class in the early 20th century.
And so you have these
really vibrant dating
and nightlife cultures in
the Harlem Renaissance,
for instance.
Or you have a really vibrant
queer dating culture.
We didn't even talk about this.
This is one of my
favorite facts,
how TGI Friday's, which
was the first singles' bar,
was invented because
the entrepreneur who
started it was, like, we need
a gay bar for straight people.
[LAUGHTER]
MOIRA WEIGEL:
Anyways, often what
I call the dating avant garde--
LOGAN URY: More than
just potato skins.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah, but just
like Grindr and Tinder--
I mean, it's, like, exactly--
TGI Friday's was a sexy
singles bar in the 1960s.
It's all in here.
But anyway, I
think that we often
see these experimental
spaces where
there are kinds of
interracial dating
or there are opportunities to
express other kinds of desire
and affiliation that open
up and then pretty quickly
are captured and
commodified and made, mostly
for straight, white people.
And it's always this
horizon of possibility.
Because one of the
things about dating
that's different from
organized courtship is
there are possibilities.
I mean, desire's a very
hard thing to pin down.
It moves in lots of ways.
And so you do get
these sort of spaces
where there are other
kinds of relationships.
And then, it gets
whitewashed and locked down.
So that's one historical
observation, I think.
So if we can keep
talking about it later,
there's so many possible things.
AUDIENCE: My mom likes to say,
don't "should" on yourself.
MOIRA WEIGEL: I
wish she could have
told 16-year-old Moira that.
AUDIENCE: Don't
"should" on yourself.
But I maybe have a Google
Design question for you.
If you could wave a magic wand
and take away a social norm
within dating that you feel
like is detrimental to the way
that society designs dating,
what would you change?
What would you change
about-- because it's
almost like, as individuals,
we're functioning
in this bigger picture.
So so much of it,
you can't control.
But if you could control
something, what would
you change?
MOIRA WEIGEL: This is going to
sound really, really grandiose.
But I do think that so much of
dating in America and so many
of our practices are
still organized by this--
not just assumption or false
belief, but real belief--
that because we have--
again, the purpose of
dating is not always
getting married and reproducing.
But it is the dominant system
that our culture has for that.
And because our
culture still treats
childhood and
social reproduction
in these highly privatized way
that's not supported socially
very much at all, it
actually is a reality
that for a woman who
hopes to do those things,
there are real incentives
to be married here
that shapes sexual
behavior in a way
that you don't see in
Scandinavia in the same way,
for instance.
So I'm like-- am I allowed
to say paid parental leave,
socialized medicine,
and child care-- like,
I feel like those would be some
really good design changes that
I do think, actually,
really would reverberate--
LOGAN URY: Why stop there--
universal basic income?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh, yeah,
that's a complicated one.
I have to think about that.
But yeah, I think that--
wage inequality, for sure.
It's a funny thing that I
get into, the first part
of the book, but how much early
dating was often just a way
for women to get men
to buy them dinner,
because they didn't make
enough money in the city
to afford dinner.
And I think that there
are all these ways
that wage inequality and other
kinds of social inequality
do continue to shape
the dating unconscious.
And those inequalities are
still real, as we know.
But yeah, I'd settle for
socialized medicine, child care
and paid family leave.
AUDIENCE: So I've always
heard or subscribed
to this pervasive belief
that women are designed
to want to build a
nest and foster a home
and sort of settle down
and men are designed
to spread their seed as
far as they possibly can
and in as many different
directions as they can.
I'm curious what your research
has uncovered around that
from a biological
perspective, and if that
is just more of a social
norm that we've adapted to,
or if there is something
inherent about human beings
that makes that sort of true.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Well, one thing
that's really interesting--
I do tend to think
that it's like--
I joke about this,
but I think it's real.
Because if there's
any widely held belief
about gender and sexuality,
usually the opposite thing
is actually true.
So there are these new studies--
there are studies that
ask men and women,
would you like
random, anonymous sex?
Sorry, I'll get
to the question, I
promise-- but random,
anonymous sex, like, right now.
And you know, the
initial findings are,
like, oh, men would love some
random, anonymous sex right
now.
And women are not so sure.
But then if you
control, and it's,
like, he won't murder you, you
might get to orgasm, that then,
suddenly, women are much
more interested in casual sex
than men are.
And it's similar with numbers of
children that people want, too.
There's recent work,
there's a woman
named Marina Adshade, who's
an economist at University
of British Columbia,
who's published and would
know the exact numbers
on this if she were here.
But men, historically,
I think there's
this assumption that women
care more about having children
or want children more,
or that motherhood is
more defining than fatherhood.
But indeed, when you control
for, or when you tell men,
oh, you might have to do
some of the work that's
related to child raising, that
actually men want children more
and want a greater number
of children than women do.
So I feel like there are
all these beliefs that
start to shift under
scrutiny, and often
the opposite of what the
general assumption is is true.
In terms of settling
down, I mean,
I do think there is a
certain biological reality
that female investment in
pregnancy and parenting
is greater.
A woman has to make a
greater investment of time
and physical effort to become
a parent than a male does,
and there surely is something
biological about that.
At the same time, so much of
this is socially conditioned.
And I think we've
seen, in societies
that had more robust forms
of communalized child care,
or where it wasn't just going
to be a private responsibility
to take care of your
kids in your home,
that you see very
different outcomes in terms
of how much women feel their
whole life needs to be oriented
around planning for that.
And I think part of that
is a reaction to the fact
that, in our country,
in this time,
there's very few other options
for getting that work at home
done.
This is a much longer,
different conversation.
But I've just come
back from this trip
to China, to this matriarchal
society where children
are raised communally
and have no fathers,
and it's very different.
I mean, there really
are other ways to live.
But I don't know.
I'd imagine there's
some biological element,
but it's also quite
socially constructed
and also variable if you control
for the equivalent of will I
have an orgasm and
will he not murder
me, these kinds of variables.
AUDIENCE: As dating has evolved
to dating in the public sphere,
as it is today, as opposed
to calling in the parlor,
and where, maybe,
these experiences
were more chaperoned, or there
was more commentary invited
from your priest or your
rabbi or your parents, how
that conversation has evolved in
ways that it's maybe improved.
Like Logan, you
were saying you try
to encourage your friends
who are dating to say, yeah,
but what did you
think of this person?
If there are ways that we can,
as the armchair therapists
for our friends who are
dating, be more constructive
and be more helpful
in navigating
the dialogue that is
associated with dating,
and maybe the de-brief.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Hmm, it's
a really good question.
I think that-- this will
be a strange thing to say--
I think another
thing that's come up
a lot back when I was on book
tour doing a lot of radio
interviews is that people
feel this pressure to always
be dating.
In the same way that
our cell phones mean
that we feel like we
should always be working
and our boss can email us
in the middle of the night,
people feel like they
should always be on Tinder
or should always be on OkCupid.
Again, these shoulds, but should
be working at it all the time.
And I feel as if this--
I would very often, when
doing events back when
I was on book tour,
get a question
where someone would
say, basically,
I don't feel like
dating right now.
Is that OK?
That's what the question
would boil down to.
And I feel like I also
so often just want
to tell friends
that it's like we've
conflated romantic success
and professional success
in a lot of ways.
People often speak
about feeling like they
need to hit certain
milestones romantically,
as well as professionally
by certain ages.
And I think that to
the extent that it's
you also don't have to.
And a lot of--
LOGAN URY: Well, it also goes
back to the biological clock.
MOIRA WEIGEL:
Yeah, like you were
talking about earlier, this
idea that women, straight women,
in particular, feel all this
pressure to plan their life out
at every stage.
I think that so often people
seem to just want permission
to desire otherwise or to
not be dating or working
at it at a certain time.
And I also found--
I think that can be a
useful kind of advice.
And maybe it sounds
very kumbaya-y.
But I think that
women, in particular,
are encouraged to be so hard on
themselves and so self-critical
and to feel so anxious
in a way that's
actually very counterproductive
to establishing intimacy.
But I feel like sometimes I
just want to tell friends,
you don't have to.
If what you're hearing
from yourself that you
want is that you don't want
to be doing this right now,
that is also OK,
however addictive
it might be to
swipe all the time.
LOGAN URY: What's the
term, ananormativity?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Oh,
amatonormativity.
LOGAN URY:
Amatonormativity, yeah.
So our friend, Mandy,
is very into this idea
that we're kind of raised to
think that the goal in life
is to find one partner and
everything is leading up
to this moment of romance.
And actually, perhaps lots
of people are happy single,
and that's not necessarily
the goal in everything.
So what does it mean for society
to take a step back and say,
perhaps it's OK
for a woman to be
seeking something other
than ultimate coupledom
and partnership?
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah.
And I think that,
again, it's a hard thing
to see in our own
individual lives.
But the purpose of marriage
and the purpose of courtship
has changed greatly over time.
You know, when you think to
an agrarian, pre-industrial
society, you have
arranged marriage
because extended families
are the unit of production,
and you need to be married
to the dude from next door
so that his brothers and your
brothers can work the farm.
It's like, what
marriage becomes when
it becomes about love,
basically around the time
of the Industrial Revolution,
is something very different
than that.
And maybe we're entering
another new phase,
that the purpose of
these relationships
and their functional role
in our lives do change.
We're all going to live to be
so much older than people did,
I mean, hopefully, than they
did in the early 19th century.
We have very different
working circumstances.
We have very different lives.
And so this idea that a certain
kind of straight, usually
white, monogamous
romantic love is
this one measure of societal
success is really outdated.
I think there are
many ways to live.
So yeah.
LOGAN URY: Absolutely.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: You alluded
to this a few times,
the differences between
queer dating historically
and straight dating.
And can you elaborate
more on that?
Just some of the history
and the differences.
I'm really curious.
MOIRA WEIGEL: Yeah, totally.
I think that it's funny.
It was a thing I struggled
with writing this book.
Because this is a
book about dating
as a cultural institution.
And for most of the century
or so that people have dated,
queer dating has not
been legible as dating
to most of society.
At the same time, and
perhaps not incidentally,
it's also been like the funnest
and most experimental and best,
and best place, freed of
these terrible, gendered norms
that we see across
so much other dating.
So I think that in my book
there are two chapters that deal
primarily with LGBTQ dating.
And I think that it often--
the first one deals a
lot with the roaring '20s
and the '30s and
speakeasy scenes
and these spaces that
are at once theoretically
out of the public eye,
but then also become
an avant garde or lead what's
fashionable for dating.
You see it again, as I was
suggesting, in the '60s,
with this hilarious
guy Alan Stillman, who
starts TGI Friday's and is,
like, if we could scale this
for straight people, we'd
make a bazillion dollars,
as indeed, he did.
But I think that often you see
cultures of experimentation
not burdened by these norms
about what I keep joking about,
this idea that men and
women are inevitably at odds
and that sex is this depressing
compromise, that allow
for a lot more possibility.
I think because there aren't,
or for most of the history
of dating, haven't been such
overbearing social scripts
about how men are and
how women are-- you know,
LGBTQ folks don't have to deal
with those in the same way--
that often you see much
more self-awareness
or thoughtfulness about defining
desires and expectations,
because there aren't
these assumptions
about what they should be.
I think one part of the book
deals a lot with the AIDS
crisis and the safe sex
movement, too, and the ways
in which really heroic
activists around HIV and AIDS
started building materials
to help couples talk
about sexual practices more
specifically and more openly,
and how that became
really important
for people of all
genders and orientations.
So I think that queer dating
in my book and in history
is often a space of
greater experimentation
and self-awareness and
then often sets the trends.
In the same way you get TGI
Friday's imitating gay bars,
you get Tender imitating Grindr.
So it gets sort of
co-opted and made less fun
for straight people, maybe.
But those are a couple of
themes that come to mind.
LOGAN URY: And I also post
a lot of things on Facebook
about dating and relationships.
So you can find me at
Facebook.com/LoganUry.
Just wanted to say thank
you so much for coming.
It was so fun.
MOIRA WEIGEL: It was fun.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]